Cette semaine on m'a proposé d'aller à Roland-Garros, pour voir un match
Franchement, j'y serais bien aller
Si le tennis n'était pas le sport que je déteste le plus
C'est pas que je déteste le tennis c'est juste que...
j'y comprends rien.
Pourtant, parfois je me force :
"7-6, 6-7, 4-6, 6-0, cinquième set, 5-3, 0-40, trois balles de break, second service"
"Ace"
Fallait me le dire qu'il faut un Bac + 4 en tennis pour comprendre quelque chose
Et si le système de point n'est pas assez compliqué pour toi,
tu marques, tu gagnes pas un, mais quinze points
pourquoi quinze, je ne sais pas
tu marques à nouveau, ça t'en fait trente
puis après t'en gagnes que dix
Mystère absolu.
et si l'adversaire égalise ça fait pas quarante partout,
mais 40A
genre euhh quarante
"Ahhh d'accord il égalise..."
Si pour toi ceci est incompréhensible, tu vas être content parce que
les mecs sur le terrain sont aussi des grands mystères de l'univers.
Les deux mecs à côtés du filet, par exemple,
les mecs ils sont là, comme ça,
tout le long du match !
Je sais pas, c'est déstabilisant d'avoir un mec dans une position bizarre pendant que tu joues
encore ça va que c'est que pendant le match
Bon j'avoue si j'aime pas le tennis,
c'est parce que j'aime pas faire du sport
je crois que, je crois que ça se voit
"Bonjour, héhé"
et j'aime encore moins les sports de balles
"Bon écoutez les mecs, soyez gentils, j'aime pas trop les sports de ..."
Je vous interdit de rigoler
Ça fait super mal
"Ahh ahh je vois plus rien, je crois que j'ai perdu la vue les mecs..."
Non non ! chuut...
J'ai donc essayé un petit peu le tennis parce qu'on m'a dit :
"Ouai, vas-y, fais du sport, pour te muscler un petit peu, fais du tennis."
Qui a envie de faire un sport qui te muscle une seule partie de ton corps ?
"Franchement t'avais raison le tennis c'est vachement bien..."
"Je me sens beaucoup mieux dans mon corps"
"Je suis complètement asymétrique, je ressemble à un Picasso !"
Bon ok ok, d'accord d'accord. En vrai je regarde le tennis
féminin
en fermant les yeux.
"Cochonne !"
Partagez ma vidéo sur facebook
et rejoignez ma page ma page...
Ça me ferait super plaisir !
Aujourd'hui c'est mon anniversaire...
s'il vous plaît...
"Allez sur Cyprien.fr, pour voir toutes ses autres vidéos"
Bon d'accord c'est pas mon anniversaire aujourd'hui
Le sopalin, le meilleur ami de l'homme.